if you're anything like me you've had
those moments where you are bored out of
your mind
are you ready yet during those moments I
turn to audible.com download hundreds of
books straight to your phone or tablet
and read them anywhere to cure that
boredom like Carrie by Stephen King my
favorite author for a free book download
of your choice courtesy of me please
visit audible.com slash Chris that's
audible.com slash Chris
I just want to suggest that you take a
pee break before you see this movie
because this movie is basically nothing
but water coming out of holes just a
warning
all is lost is directed by JC Chandor
the maker of margin call a film I really
enjoyed and stars Robert Redford and
that's it literally Robert Redford and a
boat this movie is about a man and you
don't really know much about him his
name is that he is Robert Redford movie
opens with the splitting wood sound and
you are immediately into this guy's
horrible horrible next few days where
he's trying to survive on a boat in the
middle of the Indian Ocean as waters
pouring in and he's trying to figure out
a way to stay alive this movie has
virtually no dialogue people who went to
see only God forgives and said man Ryan
Gosling didn't say anything Robert
Redford really doesn't say anything in
this movies got like maybe four or five
lines I'm not kidding and most of them
are just like hey look that's that's it
and you can look at that and say that
sucks that's gotta be really boring
no dialogue just on a ship trying to
survive and Wow there are aspects of
this movie that definitely could have
been cut down a little bit could have
been some more backstory that perhaps
could have made us care a little bit
more about his character that could have
satisfied me this is a very impressive
movie for a few other reasons for one
it's just nice to see a movie that
actually has this much balls the script
is only 32 pages long according to the
IMDB tribute that's crazy there really
isn't any dialogue in this movie there's
only a very small handful of lines and
most of them are just him trying to talk
somebody on the radio or something
that's really all this movie has to
offer in regards to dialogue this is an
extremely quiet meditative movie where
you get to watch one man thinking about
his life trying to figure out a way to
survive and that's really it it's like a
hundred and twenty-seven hours - the
dialogue and - the arm cutting scene
I've always liked Robert Redford my
parents showed me Jeremiah Johnson when
I was a little kid and I immediately
liked the guy and speaking of that movie
that's another movie he made that was
very much so not too much dialogue a man
trying to survive in the wilderness
and this film is similar to that in its
roots just a man trying to survive with
minimal dialogue and the aspects of this
movie that I really enjoyed were Robert
Redford's extremely extremely subdued
performance I mean it's difficult
sometimes to really know this guy's
feeling and you can kind of make up your
own story about why he is out there with
so little rations so little supplies and
you're thinking in yourself what really
is this movie about because you can look
at this movie very metaphorically and
you can also look at it very straight
forward as well it's a kind of film
where you can watch it and just
continuously get angry because he this
guy his everything is going wrong I mean
everything goes wrong throughout this
movie that could possibly go wrong
but the thing did impress me about this
movie was Robert Redford's performance
and just the bravery of this movie in
general there were some problems with it
though some things that I found very
disappointing for one like I said there
are times in this movie where it does
get a little boring and you're thinking
to yourself I really would like
something to happen right now or I would
like to know more about this guy because
I had a hard time seeing a character I
didn't see a character because there is
no character there's no backstory I
don't think his name is ever spoken or
acknowledged in the film he's just
Robert Redford and I was just like man
this sucks that Robert Redford is almost
dying in every scene of this movie I
hope he survives and so for that reason
I was a little letdown because I wanted
to get into a character and not just the
situation and the movie is so much about
the situation that I couldn't care as
much about him because I didn't care
about him as a character I like Robert
Redford he was great the movie but I
wanted to know more about his character
but what was so effective about this
movie was how isolated I began to feel
as the runtime continued you begin to
feel absolutely alone you really feel
this guy's plight and for that reason
it's an impressive film in that regard I
just wish that you knew a little bit
more about his character and you could
care a little bit more about his
character and perhaps that there was a
way to have more dialogue nevertheless
this is still an impressive movie and
I'm gonna give all its lost of B so guys
my question to you is do you have a type
of film like this where one character is
just trying to survive the entire time
what is your favorite movie like that as
always guys thanks very much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuff nice
you
[Music]